le nouveau vélo qui aurait dû donner le
sourire à denise mais qu'elle a dû
acheter à contrecoeur j'étais prête à
passer j'arrive ici puis mon vélo qui
habituellement est en dessous des 3 b 6
on la mettait plutôt
bien des cyclistes vivre avec la crainte
d'être victimes de vols et pour cause
environ 2000 vélos sont déclarés volés
auprès du spvm tous les ans ces données
sous-estiment le fléau selon vélo québec
qui évalue à plus de 60 mille le nombre
de vélos disparus par année dans la
métropole on a coutume de dire que sur
dix cyclistes qui se feront voler leur
vélo un cycliste sur des dix renoncera
carrément à ce rachat un vélo et
arrêtera de faire du vélo c'est vraiment
regrettable
c'est sans compter les bicyclettes des
montées en pleine rue de trois par
semaine certainement des roues volé ce
marchand de vélos en sait quelque chose
les pièces sont si rares que leur prix a
explosé une bonne affaire qu'on flairer
les voleurs effectivement il ya de plus
en plus de valeur à voler quelque chose
qui va les vendent alors qu'yvon 40 $
parce qu'on voit des choses qui ont
doublé seul une traction des vélos volés
sont retrouvés par les policiers
cet homme a choisi de se faire justice
lui même vol il ya une semaine il
retrouve son vélo sur le site de revente
dans les heures suivantes son stratagème
il fait une offre d'achat demande à
essayer le vélo puis des comptes à toute
vitesse avec succès son identité demeure
confidentielle par crainte de
représailles à quel point tu t'es dit
c'est la police qui va leur trouver
nulle aucune chance
d'après moi que la police soit en mesure
de prouver aux volets mais l'audace en
un prix il reçoit maintenant des menaces
ce point de bonnes des on voit les
différents scénarios qui se produisent
lors des achats et reventes et tous ont
le don de se faire justice soi même
c'est jamais bon
dans cet immeuble à condos les vols à
répétition ont poussé les propriétaires
à l'action qu'on a des caméras mais na
qui permet de voir tout au fond du
garage ils ont mis sur pied un système
de surveillance munis de signalements
pour piéger les cambrioleurs un
contrevenant s'étaient infiltrés à six
reprises avant que les policiers ne lui
mette la main au collet a tout pour
réussir pas la peine on se rend compte
qu'il fait beau
pour protéger son nouvel achat emmanuel
a opté pour l'application au garage 5 de
9 une solution qui permet d'enregistrer
son vélo auprès du spvm personnes d'y
associer mon vélo on s'entraide
au poste 44 une douzaine de vélo ne
pourront pas être remis à leurs
propriétaires
faute d'identification
les vélos qui sont voilées présentement
n'ont pas cette protection d'un garage
chaque de neuf non politique avec un peu
plus de 7000 abonnés à montréal
l'expérience de garage 5 de 9 est encore
jeune mais elle aurait permis de réduire
les vols de 40% à vancouver
et c'est jean philippe yllouz radio
canada montréal